each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
very happy to have our deep mantle here
to give the crypto colloquium a ver dip
is a student at the University of
Luxembourg advised by jean-sebastien
coron he works on a lot of very
interesting stuff in crypto and linkage
functions in differentiability more
recently fully homomorphic encryption
he'll tell us about a home or quick
interruption over the integers with
short error public kids ok stands vinod
for the introduction so today is the
talk is about fully encryption over the
integers and with shorter public key and
by shorter women this time actually we
can implement it not really efficient
but we can do something anyway so this
is a joint joint work with John Chavis
Thea David nakash and Merritt aboushi so
ok so in the whole presentation there
will be lots of nasty equations but at
least I hope I will be able to convey a
basic message so bye Oh morphic
encryption we mean its encryption scheme
when we support when it supports the
operations on the encrypted data so we
have the RSA which is a multiplicative
home of fake encryption scheme so given
a ciphertext C 1 which is M 13 / e we
can just write we get the encryption of
c1 c2 and we also have the relatively
home of fixed Kim D 2 pi am so over here
also just if we multiply the ciphertext
we can get the encryption for the masses
m1 plus m2 and for fully mobile
encryption we mean it should support
both addition and multiplication and as
many times as you want so it was a open
problem until Gentry's breakthrough
results into 2009
so suppose over here we restrict
ourselves to the encryption a of bits
only 0 or 1 so you encrypt the bits will
it will get a lot big will be a big
hypertext and with full effect property
given a of B 0 and b or b 1 we should be
able to compute yo b0x or B 0 B 1 and
also b0 and b1 and not only that if it
is if it is fully more fake if we have a
circuit with XOR gates and an gets given
the input bits in the encrypted from
form one should be able to compute the
output bits in the encrypted form
without knowing the private key so this
is some application of paloma fake
encryption suppose we have a you have a
software so that given your past income
past revenue and income and all the
sensitive information it can predict the
future stock price of your company but
of course I do not want to give you the
hour my sis sensitive information and
the guy who has the software you you do
not want to give me the software so how
do we do it if we have a home fake
encryption I have available I can
encrypt all my inputs using full full
encryption and you have the software you
can process my input so veeam the my
viewing your software as a circuit and
then you send me the result in an
encrypted form and I will get back my
predicted stock price so this is just
one application there turns up
application if we can build a efficient
of pulliam inscription
yes
well if you ask sufficient amount that
means questions Chris the prediction for
4,000 times you would do the prediction
from the result i get i can try to guess
what your particular oh yeah of course
you can write it best be the circuit is
very yes yeah you can always learn what
the far from the socket we may be able
to yet it's just getting named without
them but that's equivalent to getting
their syllabic sense you can learn from
input on texas the neck or so you can't
say a private if you can say it's
private under certain conditions
obviously surgery a success yeah mrs.
inherit all this doesn't gamble
so Gentry scheme in stock 2009 that was
the first fully afuck scheme so it was
based on lattices and recently in 2011
gentry and had a Harvick they have given
a implementation of the scheme and they
have a public key size as around over
2gb and ciphertext refresh time around
half an hour and also in the 2010 by DS
Gentry Holloway and be known we had one
fully homomorphic encryption scheme
which was much more conscious
conceptually simpler however the
performance was a not better than the
gentry scheme and it was still under
active impractical public key size were
was more than 2 to the power 16 bits and
main selling point of that result was it
was really simple to understand compared
to the other the previous result and in
our work what you do we show how we can
reduce the public key size in this in
its a simpler scheme / integers and our
part implementation results are now
actually comparable to the this
implementation by Gentry halevi of the
original home fix Kim and of in fact
from the results our result
implementation results a little bit
better but still we cannot compare
because security levels and the sequel
those are completely different in two
problems so this is the dj's big scheme
from Europe 2010 to generate for key
generation we have
eight of tau public integers and what we
do at first we generate a odd integer p
and keep that as a secret and then we we
as public key we output p a p a p qi
plus RI q zar q is generated randomly so
that AP is secret and p qy + RI is your
search for properties TV so two eyes are
there n integers nothing oh maybe
they're odd yeah random integers here
depends oh so this decisive these inner
bits we need you to be 18 is Wyatt gets
to get do not be insecure it will have
to square the misdemeanor possession
they will see about the security like
the parameter of shocking so this is the
scheme if we intuitively so we have a
set of excise as per public key and so
size of pzt bit size of excise gamma
beat and size of our eyes robits that's
what we our consumption so if you want
to encrypt a message 0 or 1 we just
choose a random subset s of 12 tau and a
random integer R which is and a
secondary noise parameter between in
some other interval and we encrypted as
see as em plus tour plus the twice
summation over X I swear excise are
taken from our random subset and to
decrypt the see what we all we need to
do is just take see mod p and mod 2
now noise in cipher text is our prime
which is R plus sum over I and for
correct decryption we always want this
noise to be less than P the decryption
works as you are take a mod p as long as
the noise is less than or prime p i
think in the pod integrate so for
homework addition we just add c1 c1 plus
c2 and take so everything works as long
as our noises remain less than P so r 1
plus r r1 prime plus r2 prime should be
less than P or r1 prime plus x back to
prime it also should be less than P and
the important point is noise grows with
every home afek addition or
multiplication and more in
multiplication than addition here say
see simplest or framework p it's not
you're not saying that it's a number
smaller than pho
so because you don't know what B is so
definitely
sorry i fell so you say see so the see
here yeah it's different from the sea in
the previous slide right it's Fisher the
previous life yeah yeah so here when you
say right so the see here is m plus 2
times some noise yeah plus a multiple of
pace that's what you yeah yeah so the
death count equals so that's like a coup
and that's true in like model oh yeah
sorry about that so so everything should
work as long as our noise it remains a
less than P so because of that our
operations they becomes limited so this
is this this scheme what you call
somewhat homomorphic scheme now it then
comes the gentes technique we start from
a sama somewhat homomorphic scheme which
can allow only power only a polynomial
of small degree and with that if we
apply gentle stick technique we can make
it some fully home for more feel so
first step would be to squash the
recording positive so what do we mean by
that so that the decryption circuit we
should be able to express that as a
polynomial of low degree and and the low
degree should be lower than the home of
your cooperation is supporting
so this is the ciphertext patient
procedure over here maybe so we have the
ciphertext bits and secret cubits and
the decryption subcircuit gives us the
plaintext and as this is somewhat home
fix Kim if we replace this ciphertext by
encryption of the ciphertext bits and
this secret key by some encryption of
secret key bits here we should get
encryption of plaintext bits that means
instead of this ciphertext will get
under ciphertext and why is it important
this will actually help us to reduce the
noise loins so the problem was before if
we if we are doing more multiplications
the noise was growing and with this
ciphertext text refresh procedure we can
again make the noiseless and if we and
and and that would mean if we have this
then we can do the we will have a fully
home of encryption whenever noisy is
going we will just refer this ciphertext
once again
and so to make this work of course we
need to make this thing public otherwise
the like if you do not have the
encryption that is the secret key bit so
we cannot do the Refresh procedure size
of the circuit you have to make use the
property encryption scheme yeah so the
condition is the size of the this
circuit should be somewhat less than
yeah less than otter threshold
yeah and it should be at least if we
want a month a multi production to be
done it should be at least half of the
threshold give me idea was there
compared to your special in other words
how many okay so I think depending on
the m the security goal I think normally
what we have implemented we are getting
this decryption circuit is this a degree
13 / polynomial 13 yeah
13 or 15 change the parameter Collins
personally target
yeah so so then this is the noise we are
adding our self right so it depends on
the it's the it depends on the scheme
how much it's all all in the design how
much noise you were hello yeah its
appointed by beating us right the logs
is too small so I can basically play
with it here than parade efficient
and there is a strange cyclic
dependencies
so if the degree of the decryption
polynomial is small enough the resulting
noise in the new cipher text can be
smaller than the original ciphertext and
for fully home weak encryption given to
refresh the ciphertext one can apply
again the home of a cooperation and
which was not necessary possible on the
origin ciphertext so the ciphertext the
fresh pasta do basically reduces the
noise so this is the constant on the
parameters from the DGH paper paper from
the Crypt 2010 so this is a for around
80 bit of security I think so we need
the RO noise should be at least thirty
seven bits and over here the squash
scheme has a decryption polynomial of
degree 30 and we must allow for an
additional multiplication and we need
some more eight yeah it gets it breaking
in time
70m like so so why do you say it's a
Tibetan security
maybe no sorry why yeah it's not ready
search that's it sorry about that so
surface is to know the non-self this
service number no so yeah so even for
that we need the public key size in the
end it becomes like 10 to the power 14
is around 2 to the power 45 bits
oh no I initially as i said to to the
bus 16 but this is it should be at least
this 10 10 to the power 14 is 2 to the
power it should be for 45 or something
it is already dead like but this is at
least it should be this one this is the
basic attack so in terms this is the
interim security parameters row the size
of noise should be lambda bits as we
have said and roo-roo prime is the
secondary noise it it is to lambda bits
and the size of p is lambda square size
of X I becomes lambda to the power 5 and
the total public is size in the end
becomes lambda to the power 10 and you
know in our work we reduce it to 10 to
the power 7 in the end so this is the
basic idea behind reducing the public
besides so before we were doing the
encryption using a linear form of the
elements in the public key so over here
instead of the linear power form will
use a quadratic form but of course using
that we will get more noise but yeah
it's going to be the same it's only the
public key that's er that's shrinking
yeah
so we start with a beta pairs of numbers
X I 0 and X Z 1 now we can define beta
square integers by multiplying them
together and now we will encrypt using a
linear combination of those with beta
square numbers so it says and also
before we are taking the coefficients
either they are 0 0 or 1 and over here
we will take it as a linear combination
of all the elemental publicly and in
fact now we can take beta as lambda
square so that would give us public key
size as lambda to the power 7
so now this is what will happen for the
basic scheme and now we need to squash
the scheme by squashing we mean we need
we need to make sure the degree of the
decoding circuit that is less than the
officing we are supporting and for that
what we are doing with all these is
basically along with the ciphertext we
are passing a hint about the secret key
and that
so and so public key over okay maybe we
better we go inside these zones so for
the key generation initially we take
some
yeah solution we take XP as 2 to the
power kappa bi p and then we generate a
random theta bit vector and so in the
end what we are giving is a public key
is another way instead of the PCAST are
what we are giving before and another
vector Y such that with the why there is
some a secret information 1 by P that is
embedded in the Y so we are giving some
more hint about the public key about the
secret Kingdom public key and yeah in
the previous slide so so so rather than
have a bunch of numbers in the public
key and taking accommodations to do the
emotion you're saying going to have the
square root as many numbers yet and then
I'm generate these yes Matt Lex firm
generate is number so that I do things
like but then the universe is followed
set of numbers you need to have smaller
nice yeah exactly that's so so therefore
your security parameter has to be larger
yeah that's yeah so but again we can
play with everything for that you need
to go deeper but that's true if we are
making that noise it'll grow
so
for the squash scheme so what we have
the advantage is the decryption function
now can be expressed as a polynomial of
low degree in terms of ciphertext bits
and there is a secret key bits and this
allows bootstrapping and the public
evaluation of the decryption circuit
however
so
the public key size in the DJ's be paper
is a still we over here kappa we have to
take lambda to give a five and thus in
the squashed scheme we are giving
additional theta elements which are each
an encryption of each is lambda to the
power 4 5 so what is the public key size
will be never to the pac-10 which has a
okay over here but in our case if we do
that we will again go to Lana to the
Patriot 10 boundary but actually we can
show that parameter theta we can make it
lambda lambda cube so we will still get
lemon to the power 8 instead of instead
of lambda plus 7 that you are hoping for
so and the theta was over here as a hint
we are giving it the vector of length
theta and in the and that we are keeping
a secret key and in the public key we
are giving this in the public we are
giving this why I which is
ey x to the power k and this depends in
this vector
so
now we can actually use a pseudo-random
j generated so instead of generating
theta theta minus e theta minus one
random integers you I will actually give
us give only the seed of that the faces
children random number generator and
that way this limit to the power 8 we
can make it learn to the power 7 into
power to see ya but the Civil miss
father use a secretive scary proposition
yeah so we assume that that's good I
mean some skills you guys should only
yeah
but usually the reason you can argue no
but over here we just need like like
before we are giving the these random
numbers as public anyway so like
sequester's what do you need to publish
your dream just need to publish the you
will have to use of data or you also
need to publish the scene so instead of
publishing you ones like Twitter and
amanda's us you won a you is now we
publish only the seed and the children
janitor so it's like you're compressing
cannot argue that the U is our brand of
money right if this is the same press
this key will seek a friend of negative
actions you care for you end up is we
giving out the seed
no that's only for computation if you
don't give out the sweet see this part
of the public link right what is it
move forward or something anyway those
random like those new ways yeah that
does yeah totally fine that's not
yet but
it's about if I select my
numbers against our enemies eww drive a
scheme to disturb you seek you see if
you get this behind you cannot see the
street okay but i am not using seat to
do anything else it's only done for
selecting the numbers so serious just a
compression function so you are not
using your publish the same you can
publish the sea because see it is not
it's not that you know that the
unrighteous a radio can you included you
ended up the schema secure yeah right
and now i'm not using to see it anyway
so i can so you can sneak up to see as a
distribution function with me instead of
6am here's second from some different is
to gear up using butter that is what we
already go inside the car the only only
reason you're using serious generating
numbers beyond that you know this you
today look how about like a secret key
encryption scheme and i used to see
dollar to expand the offers and i notice
published in this part of the side
effects no can do what i say also just
use okay to dance can you decrypt if i
give this you if you could then you got
it perfectly fits in better known in
this case no I can't what I mean is like
over here like those random numbers were
public anyway right yes those numbers
about your analysis it is
hey that's the flow in today you're
saying I my publishing to see there is
certainly some property of the of the
UI's that you can see a little you to
break if you see mother like my talk
right that it wasn't something where you
get sugar and you seem to get a gun for
example sorry I don't see how to do it
here so with you and so presumably the
argument will grow the following read
write to me you I so random you zoom
this game secure is your random you know
if you keep it secure that I can break
the surrounding us unless Isaac nano
daughter property so it's it's only safe
to publish as a seed if you cannot give
some communal property or if you know
exactly what property you are trying to
protect against then you cannot give the
student who see this property is like
you to fold anyway as I pour you said to
publish it because you know that your
property of time click worth it if you
don't know me in what property so that i
don't know for the security work
properly you're trying to move it is
there is a particular set of Matthew's
then it's fine I think you can don't
know what is the server
and usually the rule of thumb is that
whenever it's safe to use a PRG whenever
we don't need energy to produce yourself
so whenever you wouldn't have a total
the optimization it just might be
complicated you need you some expand the
graph so whatever and it's you can use
the FJ all right but there is yeah but i
think it is like this one we are not
using it first time like there was the
pkc paper before over that you are also
suggesting doing that so like this one
is not like i never security proof that
is only valid for the summer home of its
game if you are going beyond this cost
we just never security right to me this
what you say yeah so our security proof
was only for the summer homework
conversing and after that we were just
arguing heuristic alee it's secure
yep
so
yeah so for the equations and circuit
with that hint what we need is we need
to calculate this sister- this SI s and
the inner product of a sentient and do
too gentle avi they use a trick such
that split this set theta is a bit theta
component secret key in small heater
boxes and such that only one secret key
bit inside every box is equal to one and
that will actually help us to reduce the
degree of the equation circuit and so in
the end that is for what is becoming we
are just making a summing a bee numbers
and only one of them is zero so this is
the picture of the whole decryption
circuit we can forget about this part
right now so this is our s we have
divided in in like bee boxes and always
only one of them over here we have a
like only we have only one in this
factor so because of that whole what
happens in the end when you are doing
this edition in the this edition only
one component is nonzero and for that we
just do addition state-wise you do not
need to think about them carry
and this actually shows but over here in
the end this edition in this case this
is a full edition and here we are
showing for our tap parameter this full
for this a full edition our degrees 15
and
so
for gentry save the bootstrapping take a
technique to refresh a ciphertext we
have to publicly evaluate the decryption
circuit homomorphic ileana ciphertext
and this for but for that we need the
encryption of security bits and our we
have argued that we have said this theta
is lambda cube bits and each gamma i
will have lambda phi lambda 25 so again
we would get the secret key with lemon
to the power 8 size but now we can do
again some on-the-fly computation that
the over here that we have seen before
this computation so we do not you give
this directly we give and the small
small like of the square root of size of
this thing so that would make
this in instead of a lambda cube x
lambda to the power 5 we will get lambda
to the power 1.5 x lambda allow me to
the power 5 so over here will be
terminal 6.5 totally yeah you can do you
can do more but if you do up to
quadratic then we can handle the noise
and if you do more than noise becomes to
lunch not a nice tip but yeah
in practice I mean when you were like if
implement or not all not all so when you
implement when you are calculating the
degree of what will be the degree of all
the circuits like over here we got 15
and those parameters when you decide the
parameters then you see those are the
game or quadratic is the so far our
security proof as we said the it was
sick or under apple approximate dissidia
assumption our somewhat home of his
scheme the basic scheme so in in the
result before that one was secure under
approximate dissidia assumption and in
our case we have error-free
approximately city assumption and this
says that the proximal is Judaism says
given polynomial mini q YP plus epsilon
I that is basically the excise in that
we are giving public key one cam cannot
find P and for our AP roughly
approximate in cydia sumption we are
given this one and along with one term
without energy noise and by looking it's
tool looks solving them are equally hard
or easy should one exert multiple is
like you too yeah then it's then we're
done yeah but for if you are given just
one then you cannot do anything okay so
one assumption okay to assumption that
mean personally the third assumption
where you know there's q 0 P and Q 1
fear without error then you that because
you take the GCD you get me that's not
so
I see you what was was a proximity
so the approximate is because we are
given error so the problem is you are
given a bunch of qi p you know there if
this error term is not there you can for
the do this it would be P and given some
error you have to find out the P so that
is the approximate icity problem don't
like well to the error free version were
naturally not to them so the original
approximately know so the four with our
technique we cannot prove prove it
secure under this one we need this
assumption so one of them should be
to click but yeah yeah
to speak right
over here we are taking a rough integers
SP oh yeah
leave me here but because you can click
product away
those kind of pictures
because public sentiment is the point of
this is again a breaking ball back and
so proximity cv you don't know how
babies
but there are fries
it seems like you just cured me to be
random right from the poly probability
they'll both be prime there for a factor
you know exactly what be asleep in the
car factor completely q 0 times P is
that I'm a collector
Galatians but one of the poly
so it's not only a top piece prime but
just need to be a random an integer one
of the poly problem dates right so sku
before you know about you just you just
take a private dinner right
so does it anyway depression because
it's not all so you get the cigar
similar terms right except that you'll
be is X
and I published it over X in this case a
confirmation
location or that you get others to get
your service
acceptable alternative work
but why use the more accessible to keep
the responses i given to go part in the
neuroses
Oh
they have some physical point visits on
the shore
for those
insolence is because be than in secular
number of Portland
yeah so here we just briefly see the
attacks who do we cover so good for
attack on the noise it says we just
search over all the noise and for that
countermeasure would be takes a
sufficiently large no no noise parameter
next comes the so these attacks are
based on these attacks so when you say
sitter parameters to implement we say we
base our parameters so that the based
attacks we cannot dig them as our scheme
so the first one was the attack on the
noise and the next one would be the
approximate tip to see the attack so
over here what we can do is say we have
a tee integer sex I of that form and now
we consider a vector U which is
orthogonal to exiles now so that means
we will have the this equation and if
that one is true we'll also have instead
of X i we can just put the noise and if
you I the sufficiently small and because
our I is a small anyway the noise
pyramid a parameter using LLL we can
find out you and then by collecting many
orthogonal vectors you we can recover
our so counter them countermeasure
against that would be is the size of
gamma and X I must be sufficiently large
so what we do is we have plotted we have
applied the best attack again like these
kind of attacks with all these security
parameters and then we extrapolate them
and try to guess what should be the
security parameter we should implement
so yeah Charlotte so Nene you know in
fact I try to factor x 0
and cried mightily that's like the
surpluses
yeah but for that I think we are taking
still slower than because you get
because it the P times Q 0 is either to
the forfeits so factoring it is due to
the more the data type i keep using our
offensive which is still slower than
guessing the noise just to theta so
erotically issues absolutely and we are
making some numbers is a rough and
teachers so so the factor that will be
bigger certain harder so actually what
happens if accomplishments
we find published us along with all the
numbers about what I / 80 might excite
my Qi and carpet I got it let's go
beyond that
so here we this is our implementation
results so we take for security
parameters toys small medium and large
as taken by the gentle heavy paper so
for the large we are aiming for similar
to bits of security so these are the
parameters so what we can see over here
for the large scheme for the key
generation we need 43-minute and that
actually most of the time it goes
guessing a like making a rough integers
and then crypt is three minutes expand
and the rest of them okay except this is
the Crypt and what public key size is
800 mb as combat compared to the gentry
helluva implementation I think over here
for the same one they have more than two
gb and this is like half an hour but of
course again it's hard to compare and
our machines were just a normal PC and I
think they were using much more
expensive like much better harder so
right
so all is that nice day are losing its
doors
parameters are a few thing is not the
weekend others have this you freaking
epic encryption schemes underpin
implementation was that helped those
parameters compels a new ones
wanting to
we'll implement
someone
TV world level in general Foreman he's a
dozen compatible Buster slowly
I think a difference like going into the
optimizations you are losing all the
security groups anyway so then it is
yeah
so only the summer home perform a scheme
is secure and then but i guess i can
still is that you can do all the
operations in advance
I don't know what that much buzz buzz
I'm States also included four different
ask is that you keep an example 6
at some point I saw number six or seven
earlier versions of histo but now I
to roof citroen sighs near it rose has a
bit
that's moving so i can bring you time to
the 39 it's not
so it's not
maybe they need 20 x student that
my plus minus yeah
Oh
or rules the no I think I think there's
some missing let me see what I defined
before
so this shows that both of the lattice
based scheme and the integer be scheme
both are like when you implement them
they have comparable performance and
conceptually the integer based game is
much simpler yeah
so there's a small dick useful Vic you
guys
you like
so then if I'm given the list all the
cues are we the same size I start
subtyping with
no no but yours are all not rightly
they're all reporting on the same
similar size difference what do you mean
by small like if I take a transitory
Corbett number under the sprayer bit
numbers subtract them i get a customer
so
that are small they did the same place I
mean
symbols protect like many I think
yeah because
choose burgundy
sounds good so more questions and I
don't want